long time transphobic conspiracy
theorists Alex Jones has as you probably
remember recently been banned from all
sorts of platforms online this includes
his channel on YouTube podcasts on
Spotify video posts on Facebook I don't
even remember the full list at this
point something interesting happened
last week and I want to say something
about it during a live stream Alex Jones
will often cut to a camera that is like
kind of over his shoulder and it points
almost straight down from above and
he'll sometimes show documents he's
known for saying I've got the documents
right here and then the camera cuts to
him and he shows documents that
supposedly prove the existence of some
harebrained conspiracy theory and during
a recent stream a shot caught his phone
and something on the phone caught the
attention of his viewers and it turns
out that it was transgender pornography
which Donald I'm sorry
which Alex Jones talked about a Freudian
slip which Alex Jones not Donald Trump
had presumably been watching at some
prior point and when I first saw this I
was unsure of whether it made sense to
cover this story or not because it's
salacious and it's shocking but it's
actually more than that and it's not
about making fun of Alex Jones for his
sexual proclivities if that's what this
is indicative of a lot of people have
started to say after it leaked or was
revealed that Alex Jones was into
transgender porn that it's as simple as
he says that transgender is bad and he
hates on transgender people on his show
but he's actually super turned on by
transgender people and transgender sex
this is not just a story about that that
hypocrisy this is being analyzed as
merely a hypocritical Alex Jones who
says one thing about trans people but
thinks or feels another I think that
there's actually something really
interesting here that's not just a
tabloid story Alex Jones fetishizes
transgender people potentially because
he does believe that it's bad in taboo
in some way Alex Jones might not be a
hypocrite in the sense that he could
genuinely believe that being transgender
in his bed
and being turned on by transgender
people is also bad or evil or whatever
it's hard to even know at this point the
full list of things he said about trans
people and he may be turned on by that
fact the fact that he believes it to be
whatever right bad or taboo or
supposedly unnatural whatever the case
may be think about all the so-called gay
homophobes thing right and there are
dozens and dozens and dozens of these
prominent individuals who have been
outspokenly anti-gay but are gay
themselves and very often we say they
are hypocrites some might be hypocrites
some actually may not be right they may
genuinely believe that homosexuality is
bad and they may be aware that they
themselves are gay and they can believe
both simultaneously and think that it is
a bad thing that they are gay they may
not just be pandering to raise money
from the religious right for example and
along these lines Alex Jones can be
outspokenly anti-trans genuinely believe
transgender is bad and nobody should be
attracted to transgender people but
simultaneously be attracted to fantasies
involving transgenderism because it's
bad and it's taboo this is why and I
think this is really important if Alex
Jones as sexual preferences are that
he's attracted to trans women or to
trans men or whoever
that's nothing to make fun of I think
most on the left do understand this
sexual preferences aren't something to
ridicule the part to focus on would be
and this is bigger than Alex Jones
getting him and others to understand
that the problem with the anti trans
preaching period if there's hypocrisy
it's worse and there might be or there
might not be but the problem is we need
to stop targeting trans people and gay
people or whoever that would be the most
important thing to glean from this do I
care even 1% that Alex Jones seems to be
turned on by transgender porn I could
not care less it makes no difference to
me what it is that Alex Jones is in -
send me your thoughts I want to hear
from you about this one